PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Do you have
multiple Kubernetes clusters
across different clouds
in your own data centers?
Then you know how challenging
it is to manage them.
How can you simplify your
multi-cluster strategy
with Anthos?
Keep watching to find out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi, I'm Priyanka Vergadia,
and welcome to this episode
of Anthos 101 where we will
cover the reasons for adopting
a multi-cluster strategy and
how Anthos can help you manage
multiple clusters easily.
Why would you adopt a
multi-cluster strategy?
Well, the answer is
one of two reasons.
Your workload needs isolation,
or you need compute anywhere.
Let's dive deeper
into isolation.
By isolation, we often mean
both isolation of control plane
and the isolation of data plane.
The most obvious reason to
leverage multiple clusters
is to separate your prod and
non-prod environments mainly
to ensure the production
environment is
tightly controlled
and not compromised
during development and testing.
The second reason is
controlling the blast radius.
You may be running the same
app across multiple clusters
just to ensure that
the application remains
resilient to failures
or changes occurring
in the single cluster.
The other reason could
be tenant separation.
You would do this for
a variety of reasons,
like, you've identified
some applications that
don't play well together and
want to keep them separated.
You're running a mix of
trusted and untrusted code
and want stronger
boundaries between them.
You've got some really
important services
that you want to
ensure are always up.
And finally, you may want
to isolate for security
and compliance reasons.
Now, the other
dimension to consider
when adopting a
multi-cluster strategy
is the need to provide
compute platform anywhere
and everywhere your organization
deploys applications.
You might want to co-locate
your Kubernetes instances
with existing infrastructure
allowing you to modernize
applications that sit directly
near those hard-to-move
databases and stable services.
Availability could be
another driving factor.
Running applications across
regions and even clouds
can help ensure your
application remains up
and running despite any outages.
Regulatory requirements
also lend themselves
to multiple clusters, especially
for multinationals with data
residency requirements.
And we know that each cloud
has differentiated services
that development
teams want to use
making developer choice
another important factor.
Now that we know
why you may need
to adopt a
multi-cluster strategy,
let's talk about the
operational challenges
of maintaining multiple clusters
across clouds and your own data
centers.
In most organizations,
the platform teams
are responsible for
developing custom solutions
or cobbling together open-source
tooling for practically
everything.
And this leads to
a lot of friction
in adopting a
multi-cluster strategy.
Managing the lifecycle of each
cluster using different tooling
from different vendors, ensuring
uniform access and governance
controls across the cluster--
getting insights into your
global set of applications,
enabling application teams to
efficiently deliver software
to all their clusters
and managing traffic
to provide redundancy
and to reduce latency.
This is what we set out
to solve with Anthos.
Let's cover a few of the
multi-cluster solutions
we have in Anthos.
Anthos GKE gives your team a
consistent container management
experience.
Anthos Config Management
unifies access policies
and provides governance
across multiple clusters.
Anthos Service Mesh allows
you to set and monitor
SLOs on your services, secure
traffic between services
even across the
cluster boundary.
And ingress for
Anthos allows you
to load-balance external
traffic to the closest
cluster to your end users.
This helps you to build low
latency and high availability
services in multiple
GCP regions.
To make it easier
to take advantage
of these multi-cluster
features, we
are introducing a
concept called environs.
With environs, you can
group related resources,
like clusters, into a
single management domain.
Once resources are grouped
together in an environ,
you can then easily manage
multi-cluster features
and components across
all environ members.
This simple, yet,
powerful concept
allows you to up-level your
management from cluster
by cluster to group of clusters.
For example, with environs,
you can now apply and enforce
common policy and config
across all environ members
using Anthos Config Management.
Create a service
mesh over all members
of an environ using Anthos
Service Mesh and even
load-balance external traffic
into your GKE clusters
using ingress for Anthos.
There you have it.
Anthos simplifies the adoption
of multi-cluster strategy
across clouds and on-prem
with the concept of environs.
Going forward, all
multi-cluster features
will be managed with environs.
So expect more in this space.
Check out the Environs Best
Practices Guide linked below
and get started today.
For more Anthos
content, don't forget
to subscribe to follow the
entire Anthos 101 playlist.
[MUSIC PLAYING]